good morning heck it's tuesday i have to
tell you about a profound mortification
i recently experienced but first it's
time to manifest
second shot in arm let's go get
vaccinated we'll change into a short
sleeve shirt so they can have easy
access to that arm
sarah's driving because i'm too nervous
sarah how are you feeling about getting
vaccinated fantastic
yeah i'm definitely very excited but
also the excited parts of my brain are
like very close to the nervous parts of
my brain i'm not sure if that's true
literally but
it's definitely true figuratively so
mostly i just
feel uh a lot right so i have this
friend craig who is a great guy he's a
teacher and like me he's also a big
soccer fan and so we text a lot about
his team watford and also about afc
wimbledon's perpetual proximity to
relegation hold on i gotta pause the
story to get the vaccine
we did it we are double vaccinated now
i'm gonna go home and put back on my
vlogbrothers outfit
there are two other things you need to
know for this story to make sense one
is that i have never in my life spoken
to my watch but my watch nonetheless
frequently believes i am speaking to it
which is annoying but also i don't know
how to make it stop because
hey can i turn you off please sorry
i can't help you with that on apple
watch yeah it's just not able to help me
and lastly i've been fortunate to have
lots of cognitive behavioral therapy to
help me deal with my mental illness
problems and one of the techniques i've
learned and use all the time
is called positive self-talk this is
where you like talk to yourself in an
encouraging way and i use positive
self-talk many times
every day to reduce stress and to break
cycles of self-loathing and despair
sometimes when doing this i refer to
myself as you other times as
we like for instance if i lock my keys
in the car say
i'll get really angry and frustrated and
then i'll take a deep breath and i'll
say
okay we need to transition to a
solutions mindset we need to stop
ruminating on what happened and we need
to start focusing on what is going to
happen
or if i'm feeling frustrated and afraid
about something i'll say you can do this
you've done hard things before one thing
about positive self-talk you'll notice
from both these examples is that it
tends to be aggressively cheesy but
whatever
i only say it out loud when i am
thoroughly alone and it works it works
to treat myself like a team i am rooting
for
right so last tuesday i was behind on
everything and everything was taking
longer than expected and i had to make
my vlogbrothers video but i didn't have
much time because i had to pick the kids
up from school and also i've been
struggling with
fairly severe anxiety for the last like
eight to ten weeks so i did some
positive self-talk to calm myself
down and then i shot the video and then
while i was editing it i got a text from
craig
and the text was like i know exactly
what this is and i think it's wonderful
and i'm proud of you and you're right
you can do it and i was like well that's
a bit of a weird text to receive but
whatever i got to edit this video i'm
super stressed out so i finished editing
it and then while i was uploading it
that's when i actually checked the text
chain and realized that my
watch had texted craig a transcript of
my positive self-talk
the text in question read in its
entirety
okay okay you can still get this done
just get in the right frame of mind
let's take a breath okay you've got this
you know how to make a video you can do
it
there's still plenty of time you've got
this yeah
yeah okay you can do this good morning
hank it's tuesday
i hate this thing so what's the moral of
the story
get vaccinated as soon as you can but
also one don't be afraid to use as much
positive self-talk as you need
two get friends like craig who will love
and embrace you even when your watch
reveals your mortifying self-talk and
three like it says on my 2021 vision
board you've got this whatever it is
you can get it done hank i'll see you on
friday